you've seen the news today the supreme
court of facebook upheld their ban
on president trump fox news alert a
bunch of left-wing journalists activists
and lawyers
don't like trump didn't see that one
coming
i mean what incentive at all do a bunch
of leftists have to reinstate
the most powerful and effective voice of
their opposition
how could they what would they tell
their dinner guests
now we checked out the 20 members of the
all-powerful
facebook oversight board of the 20
there's one token republican
of the bush era 15 of the members 15 of
the 20 members
not from america from countries like
france brazil india
kenya yemen pakistan indonesia
ghana denmark and colombia so the
facebook overlords
actually look a lot more like the united
nations
than the united states reminds me of the
un
human rights commission with members
like pakistan
and china countries that really care
about human rights
just like facebook really cares about
free speech
for americans or presidents their
decision
boring and predictable but sinister
and effective if the left believes one
thing it's this
banning works censorship works
but don't take my word for it according
to a new study out today by a website
called newswhip social media
interactions about former president
trump have fallen
a whopping 91 since february since
january
yes 91 since an american president was
banned from facebook and twitter
according to the left-wing outlet axios
today here's why that number matters
when trump lost his social media
accounts he lost his once immense
power to put himself at the center of
americans attention
they just come out and say it he had too
much power
immense power they knew trump's ability
to directly communicate with the public
without a filter it was a glitch in
their media matrix it could
not stand frankly in retrospect i'm
surprised they allowed him on social
media as long as they did
if they could have they would abandon
sooner here's then
candidate now temporary vp and full-time
shadow president
kamala harris saying in 2019 that trump
should be banned here we have donald
trump
who has 65 million twitter followers
and is using that platform as the
president of the united states
to openly intimidate witnesses to
threaten witnesses
to obstruct justice and he and his
account should be taken
down we know how they felt all along
well today president trump responded via
an email statement saying in part
what facebook twitter and google have
done is a total disgrace
and an embarrassment to our country free
speech has been taken away from the
president of the united states because
the radical left lunatics
are afraid of the truth but the truth
will come out anyway bigger and stronger
than ever before
the people of our country will not stand
for it
he's right of course they are radical
and they are lunatics
but they're also in control of what
billions of people see
every day here's what they don't
understand silencing trump will only in
the end
make him and the movement he still leads
stronger
absence and the threat of socialism does
make the heart grow fonder
but alas donald trump is just the latest
target
this is what the left does this is who
they are and it's been this way
from the beginning they've always been
well
i won't say fascists but
yeah fascists too strong of course not
as california governor ronald reagan
said in 1975
if fascism ever comes to america it will
come in the name of liberalism
at the time i'm certain his prediction
sounded ridiculous to most people
but it aged quite well the gipper was
always ahead of the cultural curve
he was spot on even if he couldn't
foresee liberals
overtaken by leftists leftists like
bernie sanders field organizer kyle
jurich
who last year was caught on tape in a
truth moment by project veritas
saying that trump needed trump
supporters needed to be re-educated like
nazis
after world war ii re-educated they're
not liberals
they're illiberal just like everything
the left does even the names they use
are a lie they say they're progressives
but everything they do is regressive
they say they're tolerant
but they're actually the most intolerant
people you'll ever meet you know it's
true
they say follow the science but then
ignore it when they don't like it
they call themselves anti-racists but no
they're the racists they support antifa
and call themselves anti-fascists
but nope they're the fascists author
jonah goldberg
before he caught a nasty case of trump
derangement syndrome and it's bad
wrote the book on it titled liberal
fascism the secret history
of the american left it's in my library
at home i pulled it out this morning
check it out while you still can i'm
sure amazon will ban it
and books like it in due time
control speech control words control
minds
all control was tolerance and free
speech the left school when they spent
years trying to get
rush limbaugh kicked off the air by
reviving the fairness doctrine
how about when they banned parlor the
only alternative to their social media
monopoly
they said build your own if you don't
like ours
and then they shut it down or when they
suppressed new york post reporting
just days before the election how about
prageru videos not
allowed the left seeks control and now
they nearly have it
completely and with trump out of the way
they think
it's full speed ahead now it's mop up
time they're coming for you
and they're coming for me dozens of
republicans have come out today saying
we're going to do something about this
break up big tech
but will they or is the power of silicon
valley with their lobbyists and hefty
donations
enough to dilute these pronouncements as
well only time will tell
you like me might be thinking what
recourse do we have
how in the world do we fight back
well that's why we brought on our first
guest this evening
a man who with courage creativity and
cunning
has done more than anyone else in
america to expose the evil stranglehold
of big media and big tech and of course
now
well they banned him for it but he's
fighting back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else